i hope that what my hancock has said
today will remind people why it would be
such a wrong turn to go down
i mean two things first of all the
oxford vaccine
was developed in this country that may
well turn out to be the easiest vaccine
to distribute the cheapest vaccine
and the vaccine that has the best chance
for example of getting a continent like
africa
safe because it doesn't need to be
transported at very cold temperatures
but also the help we're giving the rest
of the world in terms of sequencing the
the genomes of the variants of the virus
show the uk really playing a very
important international
role and that's why i think vaccine
nationalism would be
a real mistake understand how worried
people are and how frustrated they are
when they can't get their vaccines but
really we need to be working together
with other countries with this virus
and there are new vaccines in the
pipeline something that's not been
mentioned much
uh hardly at all in fact is the johnson
johnson vaccine
which would only need the one jab well
that's a very
potentially exciting development um
but right now um i mean matt hancock
used the phrase war
in a way the phrase i would use is race
because what we are trying to do
is to get as much of the population
vaccinated as we can
uh to stop the spread of the virus
before we see
variants emerging which are immune to
the vaccine
and you know that will happen over a
period of time because
viruses are very quick at mutating may
not happen this year but it will happen
at some stage
but if we can get this vaccine out and
stop the spread of the virus because
sufficiently large numbers of us have
had the vaccine
then that will make it less likely to be
a problem for us
we'll come back to what simon stevens
had to say to your community in just a
second but
we were just listening a few moments ago
to pretty potential home secretary
uh i think back benchers were expecting
her to address the question
of quarantine hotels she did but only by
saying
uh i can't speculate there's gonna be an
announcement pending and
how necessary are quarantined hotels
should we target specific countries
or it actually instead to be a blanket
ban
well if you look at the countries that
have been most successful in tackling
the virus whether it's
korea or taiwan or new zealand
or australia they had strict border
controls
right from the outset so i think there's
no doubt this can be a very effective
mechanism it'll be incredibly difficult
to do some countries and not other
countries because of the way the virus
is mutating i mean who would have known
three four weeks ago we were going to
get another variant from brazil for
example
um but i just would say that
you know we get about 10 000 people a
day coming into the uk
there's about 30 000 people a day who
are being asked to quarantine by
nhs test and trace and aren't a number
of them still
going to work so i think the elephant in
the room here
is the number of people domestically who
we need to be self-isolating who aren't
and we've really got to address that
yeah i mean i heard you talking about
you know talk ventilating that question
earlier this morning on the radio and uh
there are some countries aren't there
poland and i was mentioned as an example
of one
there are others uh who insist on
establishing where you are
when you are isolating at home at all
times and that's through perhaps taking
a picture of yourself with a smartphone
uh somebody calling you on the phone
there are there are techniques our
technology is available
to make that uh that methodology worked
better than it currently seems to be
yes and we obviously have to keep an
open mind about how you enforce these
things but the fundamental
question is why people aren't complying
and that seems to be
a lot of the time because people are
worried about losing income if you're uh
an uber driver for example you might
worry that you're just not going to get
any income for a few weeks if you stop
working and so
i think at the heart of this has to be
to rethink the financial support we give
to people who are asked
to self-isolate for public health
reasons
and we should just say we'll make up
your salary if you have any salary loss
as a result of being asked to
self-isolate
you did talk to simon stevens about this
idea of the leveling up agenda much
discussed
uh under this boris johnson government
is something that needs to include
health inequalities and that would be a
massive extension enlargement
of the existing aspiration yes but i
think the pandemic is making us rethink
lots of things colin and in this country
if you are in the bottom
10 of income your life expectancy is 10
to 12 years
less than people in the top decile of
the population
and this is something we we've known for
a long time but in a pandemic of course
those people in the bottom decile
have very sadly shown themselves much
more likely to be the people who die
from coronavirus
for a whole range of reasons linking to
living in very crowded accommodation
to having a higher likelihood of being
obese
uh to all sorts of things and so
leveling up to date has really
been a north-south thing and it's very
very important that we do address those
north-south issues but i think we need
to look at the broader health
inequalities and so simon was giving
that very strong support today